miles de ciudadanos tomaron las calles
de Alemania en manifestaciones
organizadas por grupos ambientalistas la
exigencia realizar una distribución más
justa en los precios ante el aumento de
la energía y Los costos de vida
un nuevo capítulo en una crisis
energética sin precedentes para el país
lo que no cuadra es el equilibrio social
no está bien que los inquilinos de un
piso de dos habitaciones reciban el
mismo trato que propietarios de una
Villa con piscina sigue siendo una carga
muy alta para las personas con bajos
ingresos
los manifestantes levantaron la bandera
de las energías renovables en días donde
se reafirmó la utilización de energía
nuclear y se mantiene la dependencia de
países extranjeros
desde que usamos combustibles fósiles
dependemos de países como Rusia que
puede cortarnos la electricidad o de
otros países el viento es fácil de
conseguir en Alemania los recursos
naturales no dependen de otros países
el contexto se tensa en momentos donde
la inflación alcanzó sus niveles más
altos en 25 años el viernes el
parlamento aprobó un paquete de rescate
por 200 mil millones de euros y topes de
precios de Electricidad para aliviar a
los habitantes buscando resistir a la
crisis de energía el canciller Olaf
Jones extendió el funcionamiento de Tres
plantas nucleares hasta abril de 2023
rechazando sugerencias de suministro de
energía y el bloque verde que conforma
la coalición mientras soluciones en
países extranjeros el gobierno trata de
armar un rompecabezas para estabilizar
una situación fuera de control